[Music]
[Music]
what did you do that for
that's the easy fix i got i have a
screwdriver in the car
i've thought about doing stand-up comedy
you tell jokes it's pretty scary to come
up here i have a friend who's been
wanting to try to stand up but
he's a little chicken dave is my best
friend
good day i'm so scared right now
most of the time i felt like they were
married and i was just a bystander
hey buddy it's matt wanted to see how
you were doing hi brilliant hi fart face
mom hi girls hi froot loop hey
how you feeling tired thanks for being
here i won't miss it
can we talk for a minute matt it's going
to get very hard you're going to see
things from nicole
never seen before you don't need to do
this alone i can come and help you get
to the other side of this
i'd love to have you how long did you
kill me up there i'm hoping just a
couple weeks just want to make sure matt
gets back on his feet
i usually make breakfast and dinner
maybe you can take some of that weight
off speaking of us hoping you call me
grandma dane sure
molly excuse me sure i'll call you
grandma dang thank you
i want to make a list i like to write
letters to the girls
for certain milestones in their lives i
want to have blue hair
molly will you tell me when it's
happening it's not happening her entire
life she's wanted to be the grand
marshal of mardi gras
and i want to sing on stage with kate
perry that all seems pretty doable
does it you've been gone for three
months now
i thought that you were gonna be gone
for a couple weeks what changed i got
here and i saw that one person can't do
this job
i'm still a valid person yeah you are
but you're gonna don't
i don't think you're this upset because
i'm late what's happening to mom i think
you're mad because mom is sick
why are you so hard on your dad
mother you've broken my body i saw you
smile
[Music]
people don't look at me when they talk
to me anymore you're the most beautiful
woman
you always will be
you know you don't have to stick around
[Music]
nicole is my best friend too i'm happy
to be here
[Music]
you